[Music]
[Music]
well hello everyone thank you for coming
I know it's been hard to get in today we
want to welcome to you to the spring
lecture of the undergraduate economics
Association I'm Charles Woolley present
and this is monisha patio and the
vice-president
sorry for running in okay let me know
present the head of the Economics
Department Ricardo Caballero to
introduce our distinguished lecturer
today
[Applause]
thank you and welcome you all to this
very very special event
put together by Teresa Sarah and the
economics and the girls association
he's certainly a great honor to
introduce to you Paul Krugman
it's a thank you very much Paul for
being here we know that your time is
quite scarce in these days I think the
reason though he came is because Paul is
truly an MIT guy
he did his PhD here he has been a member
of the faculty more than once and who
knows what the future brings now but but
he clearly is part of our community and
so I thank you very much you make us
very proud Paul and
many of you may know Paul for his very
insightful
and entertaining newspaper columns
opinion columns in your times and many
other venues some of us however have the
privilege of of knowing the other part
of Paul his academic side and
you know we I grew up learning from
Paul's papers and we never had any doubt
that he would get another receive the
Nobel Prize the question was when and
we're delighted that it already happened
in 2008 and again this was one the last
of a long sequence of all the possible
awards you can get in economics and it's
pretty easy for the insiders for the
economies to understand why he got these
prices not only he has seminal
contributions in international trade and
international finance but also really
now an academic paper by policies to
read a column actually it's it's a
delight Paul has probably the largest
insight of ratio of insight to
mathematics so you can find in academic
papers and I think the main reason
that's the case is that he has a superb
economic intuition truly outstanding I
would compare it to that of our late and
great Paul Samuelson these are people
that can really
use the math math to communicate the
idea but they have seen what they want
to say well before they saw the equation
that's pretty unique in fact I'm not
sure I should say this but but but when
I was still here in our graduate program
we used to joke with with some of my
classmates that that many of Paul's
papers had mathematical errors in them
but they always come in pairs and they
offset each other so the conclusions
were always right
and that that's how good his intuition
is
any event it's a great honor to have you
with us Paul
[Applause]
so we're kind of trumped my response
which was the real reason that I have
such a high ratio of other stuff to math
and and my papers is I'm actually a
quite lousy mathematician but
okay so
I'm going to try and talk not too long
because my general
general impression on these things is
that the back and forth is is a lot more
interested in the lecture as the title
of the talk implies I really want to
talk some about the you know the state
were in but also some about the the
intellectual state room you know we're
where are we now in
how could this happen have we actually
learned anything from it and so on so
when I try and think about the mess
we're in I often find myself going back
to
to a an incident that happened back in
2002 I wasn't there but I've read about
it it was a there was a
conference at the Federal Reserve to
honor Milton Friedman on his 90th
birthday and at that conference Ben
Bernanke who had recently moved to the
Fed from some teaching at some school or
other in New Jersey
addressed Milton Friedman and Schwartz
and
in reference to Friedman's famous work
on the errors of the Federal Reserve
which Gordon Friedman was the reason
that the Great Depression happened
a job wouldn't have happened Ben
Bernanke said on behalf of the Federal
Reserve I'd like to say to you yes
you're right we did it we're very sorry
but thanks to you it won't happen again
six years later it happened together and
so the question what we wants to ask is
you know how is it that we got into
something that there's such a distinct
resemblance to the Great Depression
what were the mistakes and what have we
learned on are we actually continuing to
make some of the old mistakes what's
going on here what I guess at some level
the question is what every common is
good for but in any case the question is
is is how did all this happen um so let
me talk first about you know what what
is we thought we knew on what we thought
we knew was that the Great Depression
was possible first and foremost because
we had a an unprotected banking system
combined with a Federal Reserve a
monetary authority that didn't
understand what needed to be done and so
during the crucial there was a recession
there was a stock market boom in Boston
they thought there would have been a
recession regardless but what made the
Great Depression so great was banking
collapse there were a loss of confidence
people pulled money out of the banks led
to a collapse of the financial system
panic disruption of markets the Federal
Reserve failed to act forcefully it
failed to supply liquidity failed to
rescue banks that were in trouble on
failed to
prevent a sharp flow in the money supply
although there's a real question I think
in
given what's happened right now whether
they really could have but certainly the
story as Milton Friedman told it was
that if only the Fed had done what it
should have there wouldn't have been a
sharp fall in my supply there wouldn't
have been a Great Depression and then
going on from there the argument is that
governments didn't understand and what
needed to be done they didn't act on it
they did some mild
what we would now call Keynesian
programs but they were never remotely
big enough as actually former department
head at MIT Kerry Brown famously showed
that that once you adjust for cyclical
effects on the budget there really never
was very much fiscal expansion during
the 30s their fiscal policy didn't work
because it was never tried and to the
extent that there was fiscal policy was
never it was half-hearted it was pulled
back there was the famous mistake of
1937 when FDR was convinced that the
recovery was solid and no longer needed
all that support from the government the
Federal Reserve similarly convinced
tried to mop up some of those excess
reserves in the banking system and the
result was a severe recession the Second
Great Depression as many people called
it at the time all of these mistakes
that came from the past and
since we knew about all that we wasn't
gonna happen again
we had banks which were protected to buy
Deposit Insurance so as to rule out bank
runs we had
regulation of banks to to go along with
the insurance we had monetary
authorities who understood the risks and
would not make the same mistakes that
that banks made in India in the 30s
altogether that we had learned the
lessons that we were in a position not
to make those same mistakes all over
again that at the very least we would
you know understand that you don't allow
a plunge in the money supply so this
wasn't supposed to be possible again and
then came our current crisis
what
do we understand now about the crisis
what we understand I think is that we
ended up having something that was a
teched up 21st century version of what
happened in 1930 that it was very much a
replay of the same kinds of events
now things look different
because bank deposits are insured
we did not have bank runs in the form of
mobs of people out in the street
pounding on the doors have closed bank
buildings but we had the
we had the the economic equivalent of
bank runs with people rushing to pull
funds out of short-term funds out of
institutions that really were not in a
position to repay those funds on short
notice
we so we had a financial collapse that
was by some measures the financial
disruption was as bad that took place in
2008 was as bad as what happened in
nineteen thirty 31 we had a
monstrous bubble in housing and in real
estate more generally coming into this
which was every bit as
looks it looked every bit as crazy in
retrospect as the stock market boom of
the 20s what's really weird is that we
managed to have that giant bubble just a
couple of years after our own giant
stock bubble but nonetheless we had that
well I wish depress the economy created
what would surely have been a serious
recession even if the financial system
hadn't gone kablooey but but on top of
that the the major
collapse of the financial system
well all in all it looked a whole lot
like the the slump in at the beginning
of the 30s it's
you can read John Maynard Keynes's
great essay this is six years before he
published the general theory of
employment interest and money he wrote
an essay called the great slump of 1930
and you really only have to change a few
words to make it sound like it's a
description of recent events it it was
something that was very very similar in
in its form not like the great
recessions of 74 or 75 or of the early
1980s which were driven at least to a
large extent by external events by
disruption of oil supply this was a
purely internal malfunction
it was as Keynes wrote in 1930 it was
magneto trouble which turns out to be
actually I thought it was alternated but
it's more like the early version of a
sparkplug or something but anyway with
you know a small part in the car
malfunction but brought the whole engine
to a stop and we did it all over again
how was that possible
a part of the answer is that we
actually didn't let me say that a little
differently what I would say is that we
had a combination of
miss learning lessons of the Great
Depression
forgetting the lessons and
failing to generalize failing excessive
literal mindedness so let me let me go
through those in
in some sequence
we had developed in terms of miss
learning we developed a conviction that
the federal reserve or its its
counterparts abroad can always do
whatever is necessary to stop a slump
the interpretation not at the time but
but some years later by the time that
Milton Friedman was in his heyday people
have didn't become convinced that if
only the Federal Reserve had been more
aggressive that would easily have
prevented the Great Depression that
since we had smarter better central
bankers these days we we were never
going to experience that again
that I think even before this hit that
if you were looking at events outside
the United States you realized that that
was probably a misinterpretation that
yes the Fed can always
print lots of money but if short-term
interest rates go to zero further money
printing doesn't do anything has no
traction it's not clear you know when
when Friedman and Schwartz showed that
there was a big decline in the money
supply
they used a broad measure of money which
was a a variety of deposits as well as
as just currency and bank reserves and
it was just presumed that the Fed could
have stopped that from falling it's not
a little clear that it could have and we
can see that in a way now where the vast
amounts of bank reserves out there which
are not being lent out and so we we
probably miss miss learn some of the
lessons of the 1930s there was a
unwarranted belief that it was easy for
technical operations by the Federal
Reserve to prevent this crisis
we forgot some of the lessons I think
people simply forgot just how unstable
financial markets can be they forgot how
difficult it can be to get policy
traction when things are really bad
it's
another example of reading old stuff I
you can acquire a newly printed edition
of the 1948 edition of Paul Samuelson's
economics textbook and it's really
interesting reading and particularly if
you read the sections about the limits
of monetary policy in fighting slumps
it's
extremely it sounds exactly right it
sounds exactly like what we're going
through right now so Samuelson 1948 had
a really good appreciation of the limits
of policy but we forgot that by by the
by the time I started writing in
principles of economics textbook all of
those caveats all of those cautions were
gone and the general view was of the
omnipotence of central bank's at least
in their ability to create demand and so
we forgot lessons forgot stuff that we
had known and I'll be talking more about
that forgetting in a few more minutes
and literalness
we did know that
banks
were
that that that banks are subject to bank
runs
although we forgot just how serious
there was a big move to deregulate banks
that which was based on a kind of
forgetting just how badly they'd gone
awry in the past but mainly what
happened was the people and I'm guilty
of this too you looked out there and
said well you know but we have Deposit
Insurance we have guarantees we have
credit lines from the Federal Reserve
banks are you know banks can go bad but
but we can't have the kinds of
destructive
bank runs the kind of disruptive failure
of the banking system that we had in the
1930s because we do have institutions to
protect against that
trouble was of course that we of course
now it's of course the trouble was that
we were excessively literal in our idea
of what it is that to be a bank we
thought of a bank as being well you know
basically a big marble building with a
row of tellers and and Jimmy Stewart
running on a with the
whereas in fact of course and we should
have known better right even your basic
economic models of bank runs are
the bank that appears in those models is
not defined by those characteristics the
bank is defined by borrowing short and
lending long by creating liquid assets
that people can regard as money while at
the same time using the money placed in
their care to make investments that
can't be turned into cash on short
notice and by that standard lots of
things are banks
these days now everybody talks about the
shadow banking system all of the
institutions that were effectively banks
but were not depository institutions
until the crisis hit no one was thinking
much about that and so we were caught by
surprise
turned out that that you could have bank
runs just like the old ones except not
quite so visible because we had all of
these things that were banks but not
banks in the old sense and subject to
the same kind of collapse of confidence
so instead of mobs of people in the
street you had mobs of investors
refusing to roll over their repos but
the effects were the same and so we were
caught by surprise
by this this terrifying crisis
the actual slump
has not been as bad as the Great
Depression
so
and there's been some
self-congratulation about that
probably excessive I mean I'm not sure I
you know I have extremely high regard
for
for my former department chairman but
I'm not sure that the world didn't end
on his watch is a good enough reason to
make Ben Bernanke man at the year it's
but
things have been not as bad as they were
in the Great Depression and that's that
is an achievement you should
if if we look at the the first year
globally of this lump it actually was
comparable to the Great Depression
industrial production and the first 12
months worldwide fell as much this time
around as it did from 29 to 30
world trade fell faster that it did in
in in the first year of the Great
Depression but then it did level off so
the what looks like as if as if is that
the the shock to the system was every
bit as bad as it was in the Great
Depression but the system handled it
better this time around
why was that well part of the answer was
we have learned some things
the
although the
there were some obvious
failures to understand the depth of the
problem the failure to rescue Lehman was
obviously a huge misjudgment sort of the
the 21st century equivalent of the
failure to rescue the Bank of the United
States
in in 1930 the
that
nonetheless there was you know
willingness to step in and rescue key
financial institutions people stepped in
to to protect the system from a total
meltdown and that certainly helped I
suspect that
a very large part of the reason we
didn't have a full replay of the Great
Depression though it's actually not that
although I wouldn't want to try the
experiment of letting more financial
instance you know go back and do it
again and let even more stuff fail and
not not bail out AIG and all that
probably a very large part of what what
went right or at least didn't go as as
long as it might have this time was
simply the fact that we have much bigger
governments than we did 80 years ago
that's an underappreciated
aspect of the story
big government in the crisis has been a
help almost independent of what the
governments do because at least they're
there so that when production is falling
and and and private sector employment is
falling and people are nervous and
nobody wants to spend
the Social Security checks are still
going out Medicare is still paying the
healthcare bills there's just a large
automatic stabilizer role of government
which has almost surely been a major
factor in cushioning the crisis if we
hadn't had that
it could quite easily have been a
much much deeper slump
and then there have been some deliberate
government efforts to
prop up demand yes we have a stimulus
yes we would probably have 12%
unemployment now if we hadn't had the
stimulus in the United States the
but the efforts to prop up demand have
been on the hole probably a smaller
factor in what's gone right then
then then then was the case in
that then then the then the simple
existence of
a big government and the and and the
moves to stabilize the financial sector
still I don't think you should want to
view this as as a success story even so
far right we what we did was we managed
despite everything we were supposed to
have learned we managed to do something
that was at least a
pretty significant echo of the Great
Depression it's you know maybe it wasn't
the same
total collapse unemployment wasn't quite
so bad there there
that's a there aren't people selling
apples on the street but actually there
are a lot of people selling whatever on
the street you know I I don't
I don't obviously personally have any
memories of New York in the 30s but but
New York in early 2010 looks pretty bad
it's been a quite serious devastation to
the economy not supposed to have
happened
furthermore
we are that this thing ain't over
one of the
difficult things I think that that
people have in wrapping their minds
around is that the end of a recession is
not the end of the slump
that while it's almost certainly true
that the National Bureau of Economic
Research will eventually declare that
the recession ended in June or July of
2009
unemployment has continued to rise yes
it was down slightly this morning but
that's that's statistical noise almost
surely and that no one really thinks or
mentions you know and most of us do not
think that it's going to come down
quickly at all that it's going to
that that we're likely to be facing
probably years of high unemployment
which is years of huge suffering in the
population years of that will leave
really long-term scars on our society
the line is about to use well I'll use
it is the the the the worst hit probably
in terms of lifetime impact are young
people graduating from college facing a
terrible job market and and what the
what the
statistical and estimates show is that
basically if you
graduate into a bad job market you will
still be worse off than if you graduated
into a good job market even 20 years
later so there will be really long-term
damage from all of this um
sorry about that guys
so everybody everyone will leave the
room and go polish up your resumes
[Applause]
something else is happening again - I
think we're now past the point of saying
oh my god how did we how did we manage
to reproduce the situation that led to
the - the great crash of 1930
but you know since ever since the
economy at least seemed and ever since
GDP is seen to stabilize the economy
seem to and its free fall now everyone
has been saying well you know the thing
now is to make sure we don't repeat the
mistakes that were made later than the
Great Depression
don't repeat the mistake of
pulling out the support from the economy
when the recovery really wasn't solidly
in place and and and and sending the
economy into a second slump so we're not
going to do 1937 again everyone says
that the
lots of people on the outside Christy
Romer the head of the Council of
Economic Advisers has a even published
article the lessons of 1937 explaining
why we we really don't want to do that
the fact is at least at the moment it
appears that we are going to do that
it's it's almost baked in at this point
the stimulus
reaches its peak level peak impact on
the economy as best we can tell this
summer and then starts to fade out
all indications are that unemployment
will remain very high the economy is
going to be still deep in the hole
the Federal Reserve is
going to come to an end of its its
mortgage purchase program which is one
of the main things that it's been doing
beyond just keeping interest rates low
again that's going to happen in a few
months economy is still deep in the hole
if you look at the budget
the administration offered
last week this week this week I'm losing
my track of time anyway look at the
budget it
actually predicts or calls for
substantial cutbacks in government
spending mainly as a result of the
expiration of the fading out of the
stimulus but also because there's now to
be a freeze on
non-security
discretionary spending which is a to
appease the deficit hawks all of it adds
up to a pretty significant turn towards
contractionary policy taking place over
the next year or so in the face of a
deeply depressed economy
will that actually send us into a
double-dip recession
I think the technical answer is God
knows there's so much going on in the
economy that's never possible just to to
really know but we do know that any way
that we our
policy is acting as if the problem has
been just about solved whereas the
reality is mass unemployment is a likely
feature of the economy for quite some
time to come
but I think we really failed to learn or
certainly at least in policy were not
responding to is that historically the
aftermath of financial crises is a very
very prolonged period of high
unemployment that it's not something you
solve just by stepping in and preventing
the freefall of the economy it's
something that is going to require a lot
of action to support the economy for an
extended period
anybody who's interested in these things
should look at the work of Carmen
Reinhart and Ken Rogoff who have studied
past financial crises and produced you
know summary statistics what Rogoff says
is
that we are actually experiencing a
garden-variety severe financial crisis
which sounds oxymoronic but what what he
means by that is that we the United
States is more or less so far tracking
write down the average take a severe
financial crisis the United States is
looking just like the average and the
average financial as unemployment rises
for almost five years before it starts
turning down so we are looking at a very
prolonged period of high unemployment
if history is any guide and yet we are
actually starting to withdraw a policy
support from the economy quite soon
so what's going on how is it that we can
be making so many how can how can we be
replaying the past so so badly that's
the really they the question that had
worried me a lot
part of the answer is
is politics right obviously when we talk
about I
think we've all learned a pretty harsh
lesson in all of this
we've learned that if you're an
economist you tend to say well let's
figure out what the the optimal policy
is and the job is done once you explain
what that is in reality of course you
know things have to go through a
legislative process can be very
difficult to to do things even if you're
quite sure they should be done because
other people don't agree or other people
actually even if they might even
privately believe they should be done
but but not with the other guy sitting
in the White House so there's a real
difficulty in getting getting things
through
there's a lot of difficulty in
also in getting what you do understand
economically past
even sympathetic politicians
a
year ago we were having there was a lot
of discussion of which I was you know
discussion among the people were
actually going to make the policy but
also
discussion kibbutzim from the outside
and and some some meetings and phone
conversations and so on
the
the political people who know their job
who know what they can who think they
know what they can get through Congress
so
tend to always look for
partway they tend to look for us you say
we need to do this big thing well you
know that's hard let's let's do part of
it very difficult to
their instinct is always to do well part
of a part of what of what the economists
think ought to be done very difficult to
deal with the situation we're actually
half a loaf maybe not much better than
none and that is kind of the situation
when you're faced with this kind of
crisis because if you do a half-hearted
policy although economically it may help
if the economy still looks lousy after
you've done the half-hearted policy the
conclusion of the political process is
not what we need to do more of it the
conclusion is well that policy failed so
we can't do any more and so that's
actually that's been very much the case
in the stimulus I can give you chapter
and verse on why the economy would be in
much worse shape if the stimulus hadn't
been carried out but the fact that
unemployment is still close to 10% means
that in Washington the view as well
we've just proved that stimulus doesn't
work and that was that was somewhat
foreseeable but was in hospital yet that
across - up to the political people that
that that doing a what you think of as a
more careful cautious policy is actually
extremely risky because you really have
one shot at this and no more
last but not least we
the economists themselves are confused
this has been a lot of people probably
read the the piece I wrote for The Times
Magazine that the
it was has been really amazing
within the economics profession
to see how much
has been lost
not by everybody of course but I've used
the phrase that is we've been we're
living in a Dark Age of macroeconomics
and what I mean by that that there's a
difference between the Dark Age and and
barbarism barbarism was they never knew
better Dark Age is the people who forgot
what the Greeks and the Romans knew
right and to some extent that's where we
are in economics now that it's been
really astonishing to watch economists
reinventing
1930 vintage fallacies and
as if they were fresh insights because
they don't know about this certainly the
whole debate over fiscal policy has been
driven by to a large I mean there are
real disputes you can argue there are
respectable arguments that we should not
have done a fiscal stimulus or that we
should have done something very
different from what Obama did but many
of the arguments against stimulus are
simple failure to understand very basic
insights that were hard one but hard 170
years ago and and unfortunately have
been lost in the interim so we came into
this deeply unprepared
what happens now
I
don't know I'm actually really worried
about where we are now where we are if
you want to look at the situation as I
said the first year of crisis read just
like what Keynes described in the the
great slump of 1930 so that we managed
to replicate the crisis amazingly
when Keynes wrote his again the
masterwork the general theory of
employment interest and money it was not
during the acute phase of crisis it's
not when the economy was slumped it was
actually written at a time when when
there have been significant but
incomplete recovery and what he was
worried about then was not so much why
does the economy fall off the edge in
fact his great one of his great
strategic decisions was I'm not going to
explain why depressions happen I'm going
to try to explain why they continue why
the economy can remain stuck in a period
of high unemployment for for many years
on end that's the world we're in right
now we're in a world where at the moment
it's hard to see any drivers for really
vigorous recovery you ask yourself
what's going to happen you know
something might come along but consumers
are
heavily indebted
firms are in much better shape
corporations are a much better shape but
they have lots of excess capacity why
would they invest where is the demand
going to come from well it could come
from governments but politically were
actually kind of stalled there is no
sentiment instead there's a great deal
of worry about about deficits and a lot
of pressure to cut spending not increase
it so we are somewhat caught in a
situation that is a little bit more than
a little bit reminiscent not of the
onset of the Great Depression but the
mid 1930s where you were really stuck in
in a holding pattern with mass
unemployment
just becoming a fact of life
I'd like to say that everybody is really
rethinking their positions in this
environment it's not much sign of that
what actually seems to be happening in
the and
as far as I can make out is that by
avoiding utter disaster we've actually
also managed to avoid being forced to
confront our own intellectual failings
that to a I would not believe this a
year ago but when I look at the state of
discussion both in Washington and within
the economics profession what is amazing
to me as much of it is as if it were
still 2007 what we've gone back to it
people are espousing the same positions
people are are saying the same things
the same rhetoric about
private sector dynamism and the evils of
big government the same
denunciations of Keynesian economics are
just art are right back in vogue nothing
much has changed and there doesn't seem
to be an obvious forcing event that will
change either the economy or the
or the intellectual climate
something will eventually come along
right well what
in the long run we will work this out
and we will find a way to recovery
but you know how this is going to end
because I John Maynard Keynes is my
great idol in economics and what he said
about the long run which is in the long
run we are all dead
I
left the little thing on my notes here
saying come up with something optimistic
to say at the end but I haven't managed
to I haven't managed to find it so with
that I'm gonna throw it up for Q&A thank
you
[Applause]
so thank you very much professor Krugman
for a wonderful talk round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you remember us by thank you and
professor Krugman has agreed to a few
questions from the floor so please raise
your hands and speak clearly
question was what are the what do I
think of the fractional reserve system
and there are there any alternatives
which means right we have banks that
accept deposits and lend up most of the
money but keep it only part of it in the
form of liquid reserves and there been
many people who have argued for over the
over the centuries who have argued that
that's a bad thing and the banks should
should just be placed basically banks
should be should be safes depositories
for it for cash I think that's
you cannot do away with that system
remember everything I just said about a
bank is not
we don't get to define legally what is a
bank we get to define legally what is a
what's going to have Deposit Insurance
we get to define legally who obeys what
regulations but if you say that banks
depository institutions are not going to
be allowed to do anything really with
your money then what will happen is that
more and more
resources will flow to other
institutions that give you ready access
to your money but actually put it to
work so actually something like
fractional reserve banking is going to
emerge whether you like it or not the
question is
you can't really ban that what you can
do is you can try to make sure that at
least most of the people who are doing
Bank type activities are
caught within they are both
circumscribed and what they do and and
have guarantees behind them so the the
the trick is not to say that we're gonna
make we're gonna go to 100% reserve
banking because if you do that what
you'll do is you create a perfectly safe
banking sector which is totally
irrelevant to the economy and meanwhile
the real banking sector will be subject
to all the all the crises before what
you can do instead is to try and make
sure that the the actual financial
assistant you have has got limits on
leverage capital requirements guarantees
a resolution procedure
credential requirements some division
between you know basically basically
what we need to do is we have we need to
recreate a 21st century version of the
30s of the of the New Deal banking
reforms which we should remember
produced half a century without major
financial crises so it's not that we
don't know how to do this it's just that
we don't want to do it or at least
that it there's this there's an awful
lot of money and ideology standing in
the way of doing it
I
guess the question was what do I think
about China China in the United States
determining the economy in the 21st
century you know
there are other people out there I guess
is the answer
right they Europe you know you're of
this a is essentially co-equal with the
United States as an email player for
good and for real they can when they do
well it's good for the world world trade
policy which is you know my original
home field the is is set in Brussels and
Washington not not in Washington it's if
Brussels is every bit as powerful and
those issues as we are India is an
increasingly large player
Japan is not negligible even now and so
no I don't think that's the way now we
have a big problem
which is that China has become a major
economic power
while still being quite poor and also by
while not actually operating the same
way as the others do let me put that way
I mean China is clearly you know every
two years the Treasury Department is
obliged to report on whether China is
nucleating its currency and
every two years that the Treasury lies
because of course they are and
and not with what they had reasons why
they thought it was a good idea but it
becomes a real problem now especially in
this kind of world where where we really
are we we are in a
depressed world where the normal
policies have lost traction which means
that if one country pursues an
undervalued exchange rate and and runs
an artificial trade surplus that really
is a predatory policy against the rest
of the world so that's the issues that
are coming up and then of course
environment so the
you know China is now number one on at
least one thing which is greenhouse gas
emissions so it's going to be a
we're gonna have to find a way to work
out a system right all of our all of our
set up all of our institutions are still
really designed for a world in which a
handful of rich countries dominate the
world economy and we have yet figured
out a way to to deal with big but poor
economies
ya got there
alright future of Europe um
so let you know I
it's funny I was thinking about
the last few days I once had a
I
actually I'm very fond of speaking to to
Eurocrats to people in work for the
European Commission cuz they're they're
actually kind of fun once you get once
you learn how to to do this obvious what
they they're they're they're very smart
but they're also like straight out of
Yes Minister right they are and they're
and they and they talk in these
circumstances
art the other the other parallel uses I
always think it's like that the scene in
in Annie Hall where they're having a
conversation in English but there are
subtitles with what they're really
saying
and so I remember that back in in the
early nineties you'd have conversations
with Urich rats and they would say these
elegantly elegantly incomprehensible
things about widening versus deepening
and priorities and you finally realized
that the subtitle actually read we
should never have let the Greeks in
so
so it's in a way that's all I think
about Greece is that is that that's
actually a case of hard cases making bad
law that that Greece actually has been
fiscally responsible
for from time immemorial it's been in
default half the time every other year
since independence so Greece was sort of
bound to be an accident and that's not
really the revealing case although now
people are you know there's some
contagion from Greece the real story and
the reason that you need to be worried
about the Euro is Spain
Spain actually behaved quite responsibly
they had a
just a couple years ago they had a
budget surplus
the relatively low government debt
doesn't share of GDP they did all the
things you're supposed to do but they
had an enormous
real estate boom which
it's not actually clear what they could
have done about that if even if they had
chosen to but anyway all the all the
respectable people were telling them
that it made there was no problem and
and then when the bloom went bust
they have no adjustment mechanism
available
they really need to have their
manufacturing become much more
competitive compared with Germany and
France
but that they can't devalue their
currency because they don't have one
there alternatively they could get some
relief if there was a lot of out
migration of Labor as happens when
individual US states are depressed but
of course although there's legally free
movement of labor within Europe it's it
in practical terms it's not that that
big so so what's happening to Spain
which now has a massive budget deficit
but only because of the depressed
economy
what's happening to Spain is exactly
what your a sceptics people who are not
sure that your Europe was ready for a
single currency what happened and that
is a huge problem we're having exactly
the night nurse scenario the asymmetric
shock to a major eurozone economy with
no adjustment mechanism available not
clear how it's going to work no no
fiscal integration right when Florida
has a terrible slump
the budgetary consequences while
terrible are not as bad as they might
have been because the Social Security
and the Medicare checks come from
Washington Spanish social insurance
checks don't come from from Brussels so
all of the things that everything that
you worried about that might go wrong
from this project of a single currency
is going wrong for Spain now what that
means about the future of the euro I
don't know because
it is a pretty good
example of why maybe they should have
had some second thoughts about the whole
project
but dropping out of the Europe is is
almost it's almost infeasible it's not
clear how anyone could do that right the
last time we've seen a
major current single currency
area break up as far as I know Peter may
know that I think it's the breakup of
the austro-hungarian Empire at the end
of World War one and that was done by
they would close the borders for several
weeks while all the all the currency was
was exchanged and the banks deposits
were converted and I don't think you can
do that in the modern world so so we
really have a
very ugly problem I my guess is that
there might be some at least limited
defaults by some eurozone governments
probably doesn't bring down the euro the
zone probably doesn't break up because
it's very hard to see how it can but but
this is ugly this is the this is what we
were afraid of and I really feel sorry
for for for Spain which which really
again it played by all the rules and
then just got sideswiped by this
terrible by by the by the combination of
a huge bubble and the the structural
problems of the single currency
yep
[Music]
gosh
you know I really hate doing investment
advice cuz it's uh
you know I have to say even with all of
that that's a little early right I mean
you know I when I got my first job the
you know the I got this
gold embossed envelope on creamy paper I
thought well here's the actual contract
and it turns out to be my retirement
plan and I was and I was 24 years old
and it really it's too soon to be
thinking about retirement think about it
later
not too much later but not at the agents
not at that age
okay
okay the question is what should we be
breaking up too-big-to-fail
financial firms is it going to happen
you know I am NOT I
am I
don't have any problem with breaking up
big financial institutions I think it's
it's not all clear that there is any big
benefit from having them I don't believe
that they're at the essence of the
financial crisis
and there's several several layers on
that
one is that
even analytically we you know there are
are sort of basic understanding of how
it is you can have a financial crisis
how you can have bank runs does not
hinge on there being big players you can
have bank runs on even if there are many
many small banks which is more or less
what happened in the 1930s right so it's
it's there's nothing to prevent that
from happening
the breaking up too big to fail does not
insulate you from the chance of a
financial crisis conversely having banks
that are too big to fail is no guarantee
that you will be in trouble so
we can make that argument various ways
but the easiest one maybe is to is to
just say look the the stellar example
right now is Canada
which is is really kind of amazing that
we should be looking to our you know the
great moral and and intellectual
leadership from Canada
there's a new I was I discovered this
Monday there I guess because there's
more and more Canadian stuff for some
reason appearing the The Times has
introduced a new style rule which is
that we are not in fact allowed to make
fun of the way Canadians and their
sentences a so
but anyway Canada basically has five
banks plus five banks dominate the scene
which means that from the point of view
of the Canadian system all of their
banks are too big to fail and that was
not the core of the problem so I I think
that the real
if I were going to make a strong
argument against for for breaking up big
banks it would be that the big banks
have too much political influence that
that they're too big to constrain
politically that they end up being able
to write legislation on their own behalf
which which is pretty much what happened
to me more or less
the Sandy Weill
to create the end of glass-steagall and
then and then and and the legislative
process was just a formality so it was
so that's an issue although even small
banks can through their trade
associations can do a lot of damage but
you know I if I had to make a choice
between
getting Paul Volcker's
limitations on big banks or Elizabeth
Elizabeth Warren's choice of a proposal
for a Consumer Financial Protection
Agency I would take the Warren's agency
in a second I think it's much more
important to act on protecting consumers
from predatory or confusing lending it's
more important to have capital
requirements I actually think that the
the bill that the House passed the
Barney Frank bill basically which
addresses these things but doesn't
really address too big to fail is a
really good piece of legislation and if
I wish there was some chance it would
actually get through the Senate so so I
don't think I think that there
has been this is God this is the
it's not an irrelevant issue but it's
not the core of the problem Oh
big big companies
GA mercy you know again the size that
has not really turned out to be a
problem here right I mean antitrust yes
and you want a market power you know one
of the one of the good things that's
happening
behind the scenes is that we actually
seemed you know antitrust enforcement
seems to actually be coming back now but
but but that's not it not the core of
the macro problems
[Music]
[Music]
wasn't it just a mistake to think that
we could we could set up systems so that
these things wouldn't happen again to
the economy um the way I look at
actually is that we went fifty years
without a big crisis and we really only
started on the route to this crisis when
we politically and intellectually
politically intellectually start to
forget about the old lessons that that
as long as banks were pretty heavily
regulated as long as there were
there was a sort of proper suspicion of
too much creativity in finance we were
relatively safe from these things now it
may be that there is a kind of
you know sort of larger logic that that
says that these things will happen
eventually I mean so people are
rediscovering hyman minsky and the the
the Minsky who you know heterodox
economists the Minsky
argument is that there is a cycle in
these things that
that after crises people become very
cautious both in the private sector at a
public policy and then that produces a
period an extended period of stability
and then people forget about the risks
and Sunday and then they revert to all
the battle behaviors
which is basically that's basically all
there is in Minsky actually you can read
all 400 pages but that's what you'll get
at the end
but anyway and there's probably some of
that but I guess with the I always come
down to the to the thought that
that we did
have an extended period of stability
without these things happening it's not
this is not
this is not a deep mystic secret about
how you stop it from happening we we
have cut individual countries that have
done very you know managed to largely
avoid this we even had some countries
that have had terrible macro events but
still have relatively stable banking
systems with you know Spain
is now given just how bad things are
their banks might finally just crumble
under the strain but but at least so far
they've done remarkably well
and if you see sovereign must have
branches here too right and if you look
at you know sovereign actually if you
pull up their telephone banking you get
the recorded message which says
sovereign now part of Santa and air one
of the world's strongest banks so
they're saying you know trust us we're
not American we're actually Spanish
that's
that's that's kind of so you can do this
it's not that hard but it does require
that you have
the political political will I you know
I did there wasn't the people who put
together the original banking
regulations were smart but not you know
not not brilliant geniuses they were
just willing to to say we're going to
sacrifice a little bit on on possibly
optimum efficiency in order to to limit
the risks and you just need to read
Greek we capture that sentiment
the question is whether financial
engineering can contribute to growth and
development
by the way the the
Princeton we do not have a Business
School
so where is our finance department and
the answer is it actually is in the
engineering department we have something
called Orfeo operations research and
financial engineering and that's where
that's where our finance people are so
so I guess I'm obliged to believe in
financial engineering
so I
mean
there are levels of levels of financial
engineering
you know bonds were a financial
piece of financial engineering when
first created there are lots of
ordinary things that are
having having some range of financial
instruments is a good thing but I guess
we have to ask ourselves how much they
played a little differently if we had
when we said we need to safeguard
financial innovation the question is
what are we talking about and it's
almost a parlor game now you know try to
name a financial innovation over the
past thirty years that has been
unambiguously a good thing and you're
not allowed to use ATMs right and it's
virtually impossible to come up with
that right if you you see many many
speeches about we mustn't we mustn't
[ __ ] financial innovation but almost
no concrete examples are none as far as
I know of what it is that's supposed to
be a good thing you know five years ago
people would've told you all these great
you know subprime mortgages the
collateralized debt obligations credit
default swaps all of which have have
blown up in our faces so I I think you
know well I've written this right number
times thank you
there's
most of the evidence points the idea
that keeping banking boring is really
what we want to do
they take two more one way up there
the science that
progresses funeral by funeral the digit
effect contributed to both of the dark
ages and economics it could possibly
contribute to a new renaissance okay
yeah
people didn't hear that science
progresses funeral by funeral what does
this say about the future of economics
roughly speaking um no I mean there is
I
don't let's put this way I don't think
that the funerals are helping us right
now because in some ways where we are
now is that that
the
I
don't wanna go too far with this
let me just let me say as a preface that
you know the great bulk of what
economists do is not on these issues and
has nothing is not and and the great
bulk of it is
the careful empirical work on many
things or careful analyses of problems
that are not been in the headlines on
macroeconomics
what happened was pretty clearly that
in the wake of the
big changes that took place in the field
in the 1970s a
lot of schools basically stopped
teaching
old-fashioned macro even when there was
still a lot of evidence that it was it
was useful even though there was there
were a lot of things that people needed
to know MIT be one of the places where
you could still get it but but what has
been really startling in in the within
profession discussion was how many
people who are in their 30s or 40s in
economics
simply never encountered they don't they
don't understand ever encountered the
idea of fiscal stimulus and and and the
logic of why it might work or or why it
might not they just you know how many
carrots in this case the the funerals
the the progression actually meant that
people who who knew things that we
needed to remember disappeared from the
profession and and were not replaced
this you know hopefully
if we do end up learning something from
the this crisis and and the ones that
will surely follow then there will be
future generations who are who bring
that knowledge back and bring other
things that that we don't yet know but I
wish it were the case that we had a
clear sort of progression in this field
and that's the shocking thing that that
then in many ways it seems as if
the state of understanding of macro was
better
when I was in grad school than it is in
much of the profession now
boy that's a depressing thought let me
take one more question then we'll talk
why I'm sorry I didn't quite then I do I
think that what will cause a
global warming Oh
will global warming caused financial
crisis oh
you know it's it's
climate changes is a slow process
it's I mean that's not what has me
worried about it though God knows it
could but but I
the
I
think that the reason to worry about
climate change is not that it will cause
a financial crisis the worries we used
to worry about climate change is that is
that low-lying countries will find
themselves underwater that the
southwestern United States will turn
into a permanent Dust Bowl and all these
other things which are not you know
which are not speculative crazy this is
something Hollywood dreams up that was
those are the those are the the central
cases in in the in in the major climate
models so that's the stuff to worry
about I mean and there is a certain
sense in which you know why does any of
this matter if we don't actually tackle
all that but but I guess you have to you
have to deal with problems at different
time scales whole at the same time thank
you everybody
you